so a little while ago i put a poll on my
community page saying if a reboot a hard
reboot was the only way to take a
stargate back
would you go for it
these are the results and i've got to
ask the question
would a reboot really be all that bad
welcome to sidetrack your scifi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so the results are in you have spoken
and you have told me exactly what you
want from stargate series and here is
the poll
basically it says
would you want stargate to return
if it had to be a reboot
if that was the only way to get stargate
back would you accept it
17 said not a chance
44
said maybe but they wouldn't be very
happy about it
36 went yeah okay fine it's still
stargate and three percent said i want
to reboot anyway so why not i have 380
votes on my poll so you know i think
this is actually a reasonably good
example of what generally people want
and to me it seems like most people do
not want a hard reboot but
if they had to have one if that was the
only way to get started back on our
screens they might still watch it
now i have to say the comments i get are
a little bit the other way most of the
comments i get are why the hell would
anybody want a hard reboot hard reboots
never work they're always rubbish
now i would say
the battlestar galactica reboot was a
bit of a triumph i thought that was
stunning but generally speaking when
people have tried to do hard reboots in
the past they do genuinely end up being
a bit pants a soft reboot though which
is kind of what i think we want a
continuation of the story but with
totally new characters where the
universe of sg-1 atlantis and
sgu
um still exist all new characters all
new storylines you know a lot of people
still say that won't work but to be
honest everyone said that about star
trek the next generation when it came
out and look how amazing that was there
have been lots of times when actual soft
reboots have worked
they're just a continuation story and to
me i said great but if all we could get
was a hard reboot would that really be
that bad because i did get a couple of
interesting comments basically saying
actually you know what i quite like a
hard reboot and here's why now before
you turn off i have thought this through
and i will tell you a little spoiler i
don't want a hard reboot
there is a genuine point that stargate
and the stargate sgc got a bit
technologically advanced towards the end
of the series
we've got access to the atlantis
you know we've got access to all of that
technology last time we saw it it was
sat openly in the middle of san
francisco bay which i never got
um we can assume that you know the
secret sector and brad wright has talked
about that he would want the secret to
be out to the new series
so everyone would know about the
stargate program and the aliens exist so
on and so on
the big thing that separated stargate
from other sci-fi tv shows was that it
was kind of based in something that
could be reality this could actually be
happening today
and a big part of that was the
technology wasn't that advanced also it
was just plucky humans going out there
with you know
machine guns and not much else really
outgunned outclassed and really having
to you know
put ourselves on the line just to
survive never mind when you know that we
were going up against things that we
didn't understand and we technologically
were nowhere near by the end of the
series we had asgard weapons asgard
shields asgard trans
thing you know light speed engines and
all this sort of thing we had all of
this technology
and we were starting to build vessels
that could go toe-to-toe with anything
else that we came across
it was becoming star trek
now we've got star trek some would argue
we've got not very good star trek
i don't really want stargate to become
that
i liked the idea that it wasn't that
advanced that it was that we were like
children wandering around
if we get a hard reboot we can go back
to that if we have a soft reboot we
can't the world is as is as we left it
at the end of atlantis and we have
starships and we have all these things
and in fact we're going to be 15 years
further on and you consider where we
went from at the beginning of sg-1 to
where we ended up at the end of sg-1 in
a 10-year period how much further are we
going to have traveled over the next few
the tauri had basically become one of
the dominant forces in the galaxy
and
i don't think that's a tv show i
particularly want to see
the other thing is it's a completely
clean slate
none of the things that happened in sg-1
are atlantis happen so we can visit them
again in different ways we can see the
gold world and maybe go a different
direction with them we could see a
storyline that we didn't see before
we could see references maybe to the
original series sometimes but
a new show a new way of looking at it
and sometimes that can be brilliant take
something that's inspired by something
great and make something new with it now
there will be people that will say no no
no no that's not what i want
but let's be honest it's a new show
inspired by a great show so
why not
we could see something different now if
we have a soft reboot like they've done
with star trek discovery for example
let's use that as an example where they
change lots of things you know what tv
producers like they love making changes
they look they think they have to update
everything and sometimes updating things
just makes it worse um but like they'll
they'll reimagine the gold world they'll
reimagine the replicators they'll
reimagine the aura or something else and
generally speaking they make it
bad they make it less good look what
star trek have done to the klingons they
made them a bunch of
nuts basically they look weird
they talk with they changed a lot of
things about their honor and what's core
about klingons they just changed
everything now there's a lot of
arguments where stargate will be made
woke and the star trek has been made
woke considering transgenders and
everything that everybody has to be
um you know we have to have every sort
of person in every single corner all
this stuff now
if they do that to stargate i'll be
annoyed i don't think these things need
to be forced on i do think the best sort
of sci-fi is woke but generally speaking
i don't want to see that forced on i'm
not really worried about that though i'm
just worried about new life new people
coming in with new ideas and changing
things for the sake of it because they
think their ideas were better than the
original
generally speaking as fans we're not
going to appreciate that and let's hope
they don't do that
to be honest though a soft reboot could
be a completely new story and we can
leave the original alone
the other thing is even if they do do a
hard reboot
the original is still there we're still
going to love it and it won't take
anything away to it won't add to it
either but
it doesn't mean that what we loved from
sg1 is all of a sudden no good anymore
it's still there we'll still love it
and we'll have a new show
with new people new story lines new
characters new everything
to maybe enjoy as well
and it comes down to this regardless of
what amazon and mtm do to stargate if
they do it well whether it's a hard
reboot or not a hard reboot if they do
it properly i'm gonna love it
and i will be the first one to say you
know what
you got it bang on
but if they don't
they're gonna have an army of people
wanting their heads
because this show is love it is the
sleeping giant of sci-fi we desperately
want stargate back in our lives we
desperately want new stories and if they
get this wrong
they will be hell to pay
so let's just hope they don't
i think it comes down to as simple as
this
if i'm going to get stargate back for
only as a hard reboot that's the only
way i'm getting it
i'm just going to cross my fingers and
hopefully do it properly
so thanks very much what do you think if
a hard reboot is the only way we're
going to get this do you agree with a
third of people that basically say yeah
okay i won't be happy but
let's do it or are you with the you know
nearly half basically if people went not
a chance i do not want this or are you
with the 17 of people who are just like
not a chance don't do it and if you do
do i ain't watching it please leave a
comment tell me what you think and
look forward to my next video is going
to be a bit of a recap on what's going
on in stargate at the moment so please
like and subscribe hit that bell
notification you can see that also you
can join my channel that really helps me
out to create new content i don't just
have to rely on youtube advertising the
one penny they're giving for every video
i make and also there is a bring back
stargate position i have a link in
description i'd love you guys to go and
sign that i will share that with amazon
if i get enough votes so please
stay safe guys i will see you next time